you were raised by a single dad what was
that experience like it was great I mean
I really close with my dad and he's a
great guy but he's a very he's like a
man's man you know we didn't have a car
until I was like in high school so I
open the back of a motorcycle as even as
I any kid I was on the back of a
motorcycle and I was also super nerdy
kid I loved to read and and so I read so
much that I would like to wake up at
like the bus turn around you know one
o'clock in the morning the big little
girl do you have a home and I was like I
just need to find out what's gonna
happen in Middle earth wait give me five
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but my dad was so worried about me
falling off of the back of his
motorcycle that he he had this custom
harness made that he would like strap me
to his back so that I could put like The
Silmarillion right here and I could just
stare at it while he was driving because
I was always kind of like you know a
weird image motorcycle reading The Lion
the Witch and the Wardrobe and so hard
yeah I was winning all the time was you
said you as a man's man did your dad
intimidate guys if you if you brought a
date around yeah yeah my dad also you
have to understand he looks like The
Terminator had sex with action Jackson
do you know what I mean and then somehow
a machine and a man made a baby with a
really robust slightly mechanical
mustache yeah you know what I mean it's
just it lifts up and there's like a
laser beam coming out yeah so I'm people
were naturally intimidated by my dad and
he also were like all black leather or
like a visor and I remember when I was
smoking for a while as a kid and I was
assisting I wasn't smoking and I was
with my friends me and my friend just
goes dude there's your dad I've never
seen like well it would look like he was
a young ginger boy he literally I've
never seen a white guy get any whiter
than that kid got in that moment his
freckles jumped off his face and ran
away yeah that's what I do and I'm
scared
[Applause]
you